والى هذا الخبر العاجل كتائب القسام تقول
قصفنا السدود المحتله برشقه صاروخيه من
طراز ما قادمه ام
75 ردا على المجازر الصهيونيه بحق
المدنيين اذا هذه
التصريحات من قبل كتائب القسام في اطار
هذه الحرب المستمره في يومها المئه على
قطاع غزه في هذا التصريح اذا وهذا الخبر
العاجل كتائب القسام اذا تقول استهدفنا
تجمعا لاليات وجنود الاحتلال في خانيونس
جنوبيه قطاع غزه بقذائف الهون اذا خانيونس
جنوب قطاع غزه مسرح اذا للمواجهات كما
تؤكد كتائب القسام عندما تقول
قصفنا بقذائف الهون من خان يونس بجنوب
القطاع الا انها تقول ايضا انها قصفت
استود المحتله برشقه صاروخيه من راز مقدمه
ام 75 تقول القسام بان هذه العمليه تاتي
ردا على المجازر بحق سكان قطاع غزه اذا في
خبر عاجل اخر كما نشاهد الان على الشاشه
نقلا عن مراسل الجزيره فان صفرات الانذار
تدوي في هذه الاثناء في تل ابيب وايضا في
ضواحيها
الجنوبيه زلزل الفصل جديد اذا من الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي ثوابت عده سنتابع ما
يتعلق بها لاحقا الا اننا نعود الى
اخبارنا العاجله التي تتوالى حاليا على
الشاشه نقلا عن مراسل الجزيره كما ذكرنا
سابقا فان صفرات الانذار تدوي الان في
اسدود وضواحيها وكنا قد ذكرنا انها دوت في
تل ابيب الكبرى وضواحيها ايضا الان سفرات
الانذار تدوي في السدود وضو واحيها نقلا
عن مراسل الجزيره سنتابع هذا الخبر بمزيد
من التفاصيل ما اذا قد تواردت المزيد من
المعلومات من خلال شبكه مراسلينا الان
نعود للاخبار العاجله التي تظهر على
الشاشه نقلا عن مراسل الجديره الجزيره اذا
صفارات الانذار تدوي في اسدود و في
ضواحيها ربما رشقه صاروخيه جديده اطلقت
باتجاه هذه المناطق ما سنعرفه تباعا من
خلال التواصل مع شبكه
مراسلينا
لاستطلاع المزيد من المعلومات عما يجري ان
كان على المستوى الميداني داخل القطاع
تحديدا في مناطقه الجنوبيه في خانيونس على
وجه الخصوص التي تشهد ما تزال معارك وهناك
تصريحات من قبل كتائب القسام تتناول